hi I'm Kelly from our studio today my
coworker Alex and I are going to
collaborate on a document on our studio
konnekt using version control and github
here are the materials you'll need to
follow along with this tutorial a
running instance of the our Studio IDE
an asset you can deploy to our studio
konnekt we'll be using the our markdown
template document a running instance of
our studio connect with a connected
account a github repo for the project
and a friend for collaboration so here I
have the our markdown template document
open so the first thing I'm going to do
is publish this to our studio connect
like I normally would and after it
deploys I'll add Alex as a collaborator
now I'm going to commit and push my code
it's important that I add both my code
and the RS Connect folder that was
created when I deployed to our studio
Connect
the RS Connect folder just contains
metadata about the content that I
deployed so who deployed it and where it
was deployed to
oh look Kelly posted this great document
on connect but I think I want to change
the title here I'm going to start by
pulling down Kelly's code
have both the RS connect folder and her
code I'm going to change the title here
to something I like better and push it
back up to connect the publish to
account here is set to Kelly because
it's going back to the same document
that it came from here it is on our
studio connect it looks great
and notice that it's in that same
location as Kelly's original document I
haven't created a new document for my
version if I'd wanted instead to deploy
it to a different location I could have
just chosen that from other destinations
here under the publish drop-down menu
Kelly created her document and published
it to our studio konnekt she added me as
a collaborator on our CTO Connect and
shared the Rs Connect folder via version
control I pulled down the code in the RS
Connect folder from the version control
I made my changes and I published it
back to connect if you've watched this
video and run into any issues deploying
your own content and sharing it in our
studio konnekt please contact support at
our studio comm let them know that
you've watched this video and tell them
about the problem that you're happy